the Joe Rogan experience how many seals
are novelists
it's not common there are seals
obviously who get out and write
nonfiction yeah the Richard Marcinko who
created Marcinko I read those yeah the
first books that I ever read on military
and oh nice nice yeah early 90s and when
that came out I was so excited because I
had read everything you possibly could
on seals up until that point because I
wanted to be a CEO since I was seven
years old I knew I was gonna be in the
military even before that books come out
those came out in the 90s so I was odd
they really yeah early 90s that was the
first one I don't know if I can read
them yeah read World War I felt like I
read them before then but I guess that
makes sense no plant time kind of blends
together so when I found out hey there's
an autobiography coming out about the
guy that started this command damn knock
on the East Coast this counter-terrorist
unit I was so excited to read that book
what's then there an issue two people
kind of upset that he was telling these
stories I think so but it's a kid
reading that I don't know any that
backstory just like oh this is amazing
yeah I've had an incredible life to be
able to write a book and the first
commanding officer of Delta Force wrote
a book called the Delta Force and I
think 1986 which really goes into the
Iranian hostage crisis and does what
happened to desert one in 1980 and that
was a very formative time for me because
I knew I was going in the military and
at the time Walter Cronkite's on TV
we're watching it during dinner he's
counting down the days that US personnel
have been taken hostage in Iran and I'm
seeing those click down times everything
I wake up every single night and I'm
wondering I see the pictures black and
white photos of US military and people
from the State Department I didn't know
that at the time though I do see a guy
in a suit and a guy in a military
uniform blindfolded in black and white
photos on the cover of the newspaper and
I'm wondering why all right why is the
United States standing by and letting
this happen
even though I'm six years old at the
time why is this happening why don't we
go in there and get those guys and then
desert what happens and of course that's
that's on the mind is still shades
everything we do is a special Ave that
the special operations was a big black
eye for the country special operations
and explain to people what happens
though so about six months after the
hostages were taken in Iran so they were
taking I think
November of 1979 and about six months
they were eventually held for 444 days
but about five six months into that we
made an attempt to rescue them so
they're being held at the Embassy still
or an adjacent building I think and we
was the first use that most people know
of what's called Delta Force so our
premier counter-terrorist unit that it's
modeled after the British SAS and the
British SAS has been in service for a
long time so we had guys that went
through the air program in the sixties
even and they took those lessons and
created ours because late 60s mid 70s
there's a lot of hijackings we have
Munich Olympics we have all these
cavities these terrorist events and we
don't really have a good way to counter
them and so Delta Force is created and
their first test was Operation Eagle
Claw to rescue the hostages in Iran so
it's just an anniversary of it just
happened the other day
so April 1980 we give it a shot
and it didn't work out so what happened
was we have Marine pilots flying these
sea stallion helicopters off I think it
was the USS Nimitz I think so they're
flying off an aircraft carrier they're
meeting the assaulters from Delta Force
who are flying in on c-130s from an
island called massara in the Gulf of
Oman where a place where we would then
launch into Afghanistan years later
interesting way now if I spent a little
time time there and they were gonna meet
up in the desert and outside of Tehran
Iran a few hundred miles outside the
fattest city so the c-130s land ec130 s
land that have fuel helicopters land
from the aircraft carrier they're going
to refuel those helos and the planes are
going back to massara and the helicopter
is going to get closer to Tehran so
they're gonna get closer they're gonna
land they're gonna get camouflaged
during the day and then some guys who
have been on the ground in Turan this is
the best part of the story that no one
really talks about we've had guys on the
ground in Iran we had an e6 air force
guy that spoke Farsi we had a Special
Operations legend dick meadows
I was also on the Sante arrayed in
Vietnam and we have two Special Forces
guys out of Germany and then two CIA
assets
one's called Bob and ones named Mohammed
and they had to get vehicles out there
to the hide site what the Delta Force
guys are and then they're gonna assault
they're gonna go in they're gonna retake
the embassy there and get the hostages
and then the helicopters are going to
take back off land in a soccer stadium
next door and they're gonna extract from
their exfil from there so what happened
was the planes land helicopters have
some had mechanical problems couple get
lost in the sandstorm they needed six to
do the mission they launched with eight
less than six make it to that link-up
point in the desert so they have to
scrap its called no-go criteria so it
takes a decision essentially away from
the ground Force commander because ahead
of time he knows that if we don't have
if we have four helicopters we can't do
this mission so instead of being on the
ground saying okay we have four how many
guys do you have can we do it with this
those decisions have been made ahead of
time in the planning process so the
helicopters land not enough they scrap
the mission the abort and what would
have happened is they would have gone
back and they would have reconstituted
and gone after the hostages a few days
later but one of the helicopters in
refueling collides with one of the ec130
s huge explosion eight US servicemen
died and so they don't go take the
ostriches they don't go back for the
hostages again a few days later Iran
moves the hostages different locations
all over Iran to make it a lot more
difficult if we had gone after them
again but the next day President Carter
makes an announcement said we tried to
get the hostages didn't work had this
disaster in the desert and it was a big
black eye for his his presidency and for
special operations in general but the
important part we took those lessons and
we we applied them going forward so and
how we trained all together instead of
having all these pilots and assaulters
and all these people that have never
really trained together up until that
point well now we do now we have a
Special Operations Command we all train
together so pilots are trained you're
doing all this stuff together so when
9/11 hit all those years later we're
much more prepared because of what
happened to desert one so that's how we
honor those guys that died that's how we
honor that mission is by taking those
lessons and apply them going forward and
that's what you interesting leaned up
that's what you do in life also when you
have to learn these lessons and apply
them going for it's all about how you
apply them going forward well that's a
huge advantage for you as an author to
have all that information to have that
legitimate background
like to be writing about these things
like we're talking about guys who are
writing about taking safeties off Glocks
people that really don't know what
they're writing about when they do it's
like I mean you can be creative and
pretend you're a ballerina without of
every ballet danced but I don't think
it's gonna be the same and there's
there's an authenticity to the way you
write and to the one book that I've read
at least savage son where you just it
there's a frequency that you tap into
that is a frequency of a person that has
experienced this stuff in real life
you're not imagining you know there's a
lot of there's a lot of stuff where
people write about things where they're
imagining you know there's a movie
called warrior where it's an MMA movie
oh yeah they fight two days in a row and
when they know they fought two days
around my kid though what are you talk
you have fight two days in a row have
you ever seen someone the day after a
fight the [ __ ] Elephant Man right her
whole body's a mess everything's swollen
like this is nonsense but someone that
doesn't know is like this in the story
they're gonna he's gonna lose the first
night but the next night he's gonna go
he's to take you out of like you if it's
a it's a world they don't really know
about and they're writing about this
world whereas you're writing about a
world that you were so deeply embedded
in for all those years that when you're
writing about it it's just it's really
compelling it's very interesting thank
you yeah I and I coorporate some real
world stuff in there too like a shot
that I didn't take into Jeff Iraq and I
fictionalized that by having a memory
from Fallujah and so I joined morph it
around a little bit but the passion is
there the feelings and emotions behind
it are there and it's woven in to the
first story and then some and so it's
very therapeutic I get to take and I was
very lucky down range like you can do
all the right things in combat like if
you were to whiteboard something out
here and we talk about tactics and all
the rest of it you could make those
exact same right decisions downrange and
things can still go south and people can
die then the other is opposite truly you
can make all the wrong decisions of
quote-unquote wrong decisions and things
can work out just fine little slight
like life so you could show rather you
made mistakes or not point then you're
gonna have a hard time dealing with them
later
for whatever reason whether it was luck
or whatever else I sleep very well at
night because of the things that that
was involved in downrange but I still
got to tap into them and put them into
the story
[Applause]